good morning John it's Sunday it's
Newsday no stay what's going on here I'm
taking over on Sunday because I'm a geek
for good oh but I do have news for you
my friends today is the beginning of
global geek week a week in which geeks
realize how much good they can do for
the world
now John because of the way that you and
I and the nerdfighters just think we
have somehow become the go-to guys for
talking about doing good on YouTube and
frankly I'm really quite proud of that I
don't know how we ended up in that space
I guess maybe it's because we'd rather
talk about the problems with the world
and the problems with the Jonas Brothers
marital status I hear that one of them
is getting married and you know how they
took that promise Val so yeah it means
that one of the Jonas Brothers finally
gonna get to score but you know what's
more exciting than that people using
their brains just save the freaking
planet that's what excites me that's
what I want to see in People magazine I
just realize I've been doing a bunch of
global geek week stuff and so I've been
naming everything ggw this ggw that and
I have to tell you all do not Google ggw
ggw does not stand for global geek week
yet ggw girls gone wild anyhow the
people at global geek week I've teamed
up to do something pretty spectacular
they are asking the entire geek
community of which nerdfighters should
include themselves to make videos
maximum two minutes about being a geek
and why giving back is so important and
of course how geeks can give back and
way that no other portion of the
population ever could once you finish
your video you can submit it to the
global geek week YouTube group from
there it will be judged by a committee
of prestigious judges of which only one
along with people you've heard of from
YouTube like Lisa Nova and hotforwords
and also some geeks that are beyond top
notch geeks like Guy Kawasaki and we
hung the 2008 us Sudoku champion if you
were thinking we didn't have true geek
cred oh yeah we too if you win you will
get two round-trip tickets on Virgin
America along with a free Wi-Fi pass for
your entire trip you can find out more
at global geek week calm and keep your
eye out on Twitter for the geeks for
good hashtag this is a green looking
forward to all nerdfighter and other
global geek week submissions but you
better get moving fast because this
isn't complicate but that's global geek
week videos have to be in by Thursday at
midnight Pacific time and if they aren't
they don't count
so get your geek breeding gear and tell
us what it means for you to be
and why we all have to give back